hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so i'm back with a video
only on amc guys as i know that some of
you want only to see amc and i
understand why this is one of the symbol
of the meme movement and it's a stock
that has a great potential so let's have
a look at the technicals that the flows
at everything and see what can happen
next let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so let me start as usual
with the chart i'm gonna try to be quick
guys because i know that some of you
have already seen
uh my medium term analysis that has not
changed here so let me go quickly
through it i'm on the daily time frame
i'm using ldap theory i'm using
fibonacci i'm using chun lines and i'm
trying to
anticipate what the market might be
doing and here
what i see is that we have a first wave
we had a first wave corrective then uh
so first wave in gen 21 then correction
then here breakout nice impulse in five
waves that i helped you guys to uh swing
i mean i
did the best i could to find the levels
and i think they were pretty accurate so
i'm just trying to use the same
techniques guys and to anticipate what
will happen uh now so we are in a huge
triangle guys so
triangles are usually continuation
patterns all right so whenever you see a
triangle there is more chance we break
it on the upside than on the downside i
mean in direction of the current trend
which here is bullish you can see we are
bullish because we are above the 200-day
moving average and we are right now in a
corrective pattern as you can see the
moving averages are just crossing each
other it's not pretty clean but we have
a clean lower band and a clean upper
band i mean the upper band was very
clean it was like that before we had
this breakout that last as i showed you
guys during my life uh two days ago that
lasts only three hours all right only
three hours spent above the upper band
the triangle upper band which is not
enough to be considered as a breakout i
mean not a trustful one so we get we had
this rejection and from there guys i
needed to update slightly my trend line
this is something you need to be able to
do as well whenever the price action is
giving you a level that is beyond the
trend line you had you need to take it
into account so this is the nutrient
line i'm having it's not changing much
you can see that 44 is gonna be the
level we're gonna need to break out
above uh for this fifth wave to start we
are not in the fifth wave yet i was
hoping we were here i had accounting
like that before and here i was
expecting it it's one two and then three
four five but uh the strong rejection
here tells me that actually this was a d
wave and that we are in uh an e wave
right now so what are the different
scenarios that we can have from here
first to know what is the medium term uh
trend you can have a look at the 20 and
50 day moving averages you can see that
here we are
between the two of them so we are kind
of neutral uh we got rejected by the 50
day moving average at 40.4 yesterday on
friday session we still closed the day
higher which is quite positive to me but
i am kind of neutral right now for the
coming week
we can
go right away test 44 maybe break it
this time babies get slightly rejected
and break it this is one scenario the
alternative scenario
is not that bad it's just that we're
gonna find you know e-waves they are
usually zigzags all right so
we can
have something like this all right this
could be totally acceptable so we go
maybe slightly higher we get rejected
right away we found more support here
and then we have this breakout so
i don't believe we can break this lower
this triangle lower band but be aware
that if we do it's not looking good we
still have more supports below we can
still move the trend line a little bit
so it's going to be fine here we had a
little bit of a fake out but if we break
it with volume it's not looking good but
of course this is not one of my you know
strong scenarios either we go right away
to 44 or we get back some liquidity
lower before breaking out and once we
break out guys i mean a real breakout
not like the one we had here uh just
holding three hours let me show you
again guys he will spend only three
hours above this trend line that has
been moved right now but it was here so
one two three i'm on the one hour time
frame only three or four candles above
that level which is not trustful enough
for medium term analysis so now what we
want to see guys is a full day above the
44 level
where is the 44 level it disappeared let
me put it back so here there's a little
fake out above 44 but 44 was the recent
high and here you can see we almost
tested it it's 44.3 something like this
so usually when you have those intersect
between two trend lines so here the
intersect is on the 22nd of november at
44. usually the market likes to go
through those levels so let's see but
my preferred scenario is that something
happens either bullish or bearish but
that we end up coming here and let's see
what happens i believe the breakout is
coming soon we have until if i
don't change my trend lines which i
might do a little bit just like you saw
but if i don't change it anymore we are
converging on the 22nd of december so
the move needs to happen before up or
down i believe it's going to be on the
upside why so first as you can see i
miss one wave okay first reason second
reason this shot is bullish
because we are above the 200-day moving
average third reason we are in a
triangle that usually are in force waves
and fifth reason guys bam look at that
you know the spreadsheet but let's check
together where we are in terms of
synthetic short and in terms of
especially i want to check the 145
strike has it grown or not we were at 17
million
last time i have checked
with you guys so let's see this time
20 million guys all right so what else
can i say this is growing this is
showing how bullish people are this is
showing
how it's going to be a big trouble for
option market makers and for shorts uh
if we go close to this level so we are
not there yet i know but this is a good
information this is my fifth reason for
being bullish on amc what else do we
have the synthetic shot is at
7.5
the maximum is at 20
let's compare that with what we had in
the past i just added here
bam so look at the dtc guys okay
august september october blah blah blah
i do it every two weeks roughly so you
can see the
synthetic shot
is roughly stable even a bit lower than
usual at seven percent
but the dtc is growing and this is the
dtc that you guys want to pay attention
to because it's it's it means that
shorts need three days
if they trade the daily volume to
cover the positions or the other way
around they need to trade three times
the average daily volume to uh the
monthly average daily volume to cover
the positions so usually between five
and ten it's a squeeze we are three
point three so this can happen any time
and once again the 145 strike is huge
guys huge 20 million is the biggest one
i've seen we're talking exactly about
19.8 million all right so it's big and
where is it coming from you guys know
where it's coming from gen 22
okay so
350 i'm also going to pay attention a
lot guys to the option roll
in gen 22 let's say you know nothing
happened it's possible right unlikely
but possible and i'm gonna check if
people roll the the option to march 22
or jan 23 for now we're having 170 000
options on march and jan 23 march 22 jan
23 and we have 340 000 here so i'm going
to pay attention to that it's a very and
200 000 on december so
first from december to jan you know
basically paying attention to the number
of total options which is basically the
synthetic short but the maturity is very
important because the shorter the more
explosive it is and so paying attention
to this is what is helping me to build
my views to find my scenarios and here i
can tell you that the biggest strike is
at 40 so
that's why whenever we get close uh to
4d we have big moves we should have big
moves because we have some gamma
so
here for example you can see we went
through 40 and big move
big move okay i'm checking only the past
few days here the scandal was a huge
candle through the 4d level here we went
quite smoothly through it but then we
had this huge run up then brutally be
below so let's see but if we are able to
tread at 42 on monday
i think that we go to 44 you know for
the same reason we have a lot of gamma
all right guys so whenever you have
gamma the moves are amplified what else
can i tell you guys it's pretty much
pretty much it guys i'm gonna keep
following that of course uh i'm
personally gonna be a buyer around 37 38
if we go lower and yeah let's just
finish uh giving you once again the
targets guys don't change you know my
method i like to apply fibonacci and
elliot wave combined i measure one plus
three applied to the bottom of the force
wave and i go to the uh one two one or
one to one point six one eight ratio
protection field production ratio which
is ninety five hundred and thirty five
so i personally do believe we're going
to reach those levels i don't know if
it's going to be before jan or maybe
before march but something huge is going
to happen before at the end of the year
because we have this triangle that is
converging and the market needs to
choose a direction so that's it for me i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget guys to
click on the sub like and bell button so
you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to show i'll see you guys